a 360 degree panoramic dome microwave
and air in shower technology uses 35%
less water by putting tiny air bubbles
inside each droplet of water Vsauce
Kevin here this is mine
Ghent University in Belgium has
developed a contact lens that displays
text the transparent lens can modulate
the transmitted light using LCD
technology and the image is visible to
other people not the wearer but they are
currently researching ways to display
text to the person wearing the lens and
hope to create a way for Road directions
text messages and emails to be on your
eyes within five years DARPA is
developing a foam to help wounded
soldiers mitigate damage from internal
hemorrhaging the wound stasis technology
is designed to be administered on the
battlefield and works with two liquid
phases injected internally that mix to
become foam which moulds around the
organs compressing internal wounds until
the patient can be safely transported to
a surgeon who then easily removes the
foam and treats the injury
Kenshiro is a humanoid robot that copies
your muscles and bones it's the closest
to a human form so far and mimics the
body of the average Japanese 12 year old
male with the same weight ratios it has
160 pulley like muscles does squats and
features aluminum bones newly discovered
Laura's Czech brand new species check
extremely cute Czech venomous teeth
check gravity light is an alternative to
kerosene lamps that harnesses the power
of gravity the LED lanterns cost less
than $10 to buy with no running costs
and the 3 seconds it takes to lift the
weight made up of a bag filled with
rocks or dirt powers the light for half
an hour it has no batteries is
specifically for countries without
reliable access to mains electricity and
you can find out more over at their
website University of Bath researchers
are claiming that vector-based video
will lead to the death of the pixel
within the next 5 years
digital pictures are made up of a
rectangular grid of colored cells or
pixels the smaller and closer together
the higher the quality and amount of
data that needs to be compressed but
vectors present contoured colors with
the highest visual quality without a
bunch of pixels needing to be compressed
and they say this will revolutionize the
way visual media is produced yo you got
sneaker speakers yeah all right
neuroscientists and software engineers
at the University of Waterloo in Canada
have built the most complex artificial
brain ever spawn isn't just a
supercomputer mimics the structure of a
real brain and has 2.5 million simulated
neurons constructed to pattern the
brains cranial subsystems it also has a
digital eye for visual input a robot arm
to draw responses and can pass very
basic IQ tests finally further up yonder
is a time-lapse from the International
Space Station put together by giacomo
Tsar deli at the most for deployed
citizens of the planet be the first
expedition crew aboard Space Station how
funny
we are well started on our journey of
exploration and discovery building a
foothold for fat women
voyage and with
far away from our home planet they are
opening the gateway to space wrong I'm
gonna leave you with a radar sequence of
an asteroid that's over 4 million miles
away from Earth and as always thanks for
watching